we're actually going to begin this hour
with some breaking news on a prison
prisoner exchange between the united
states and russia trevor reed a former
u.s marine arrested in russia nearly
three years ago is coming home reid had
been accused of assaulting a russian
police officer and was being while he
was being driven to a police station
after a night of heavy drinking when
this incident allegedly occurred it's
been deemed falsely he's been deemed as
falsely imprisoned by his family since
this happened in the summer of 2019.
reid was tried and sentenced to nine
years in prison in russia again he
always maintained his innocence and the
u.s government said he was indeed
wrongly wrongfully imprisoned a reed was
swapped in this extraordinary exchange
even in peace times this morning for a
russian pilot who was serving a 20-year
sentence in the u.s for a cocaine
smuggling conspiracy he was
in the state of uh
connecticut uh it's a very unusual
situation uh uh here even in peace times
this sort of high-level prisoner swap is
unusual the fact that it happened uh in
an undisclosed european country we're
told while this conflict is going on in
ukraine is particularly extraordinary uh
joe biden in a statement
says that he's delighted to share the
good news with the reed family
understanding how much they were worried
about his health and missed his presence
and the reed family in the statement
said our prayers have been answered they
thank the president for his kindness his
consideration and for making the
decisions you've seen many interviews
with the reed family so i spoke to the
imagination yes my colleagues green and
i on cbs new streaming uh spoke to joey
and paula reed
who never stopped when did this uh i
want to say maybe about two weeks ago
two and a half weeks ago they came in
our air on cbs news and uh they talked
to us about their efforts to try and get
him to release they met with president
biden they talked to us about that they
have been at the forefront of trying to
get him released from the moment that he
was taken by the russian authorities and
they never stopped believing they uh mr
reed went to russia uh to work with the
russian authorities there and russian
lawyers um and now president biden has
delivered them really good news
especially when there's so much tension
between the two countries this is great
for the reed family and for trevor yeah
that's great and i know now there's some
other hopeful families because attention
turns to other americans still in russia
like wnb star uh brittany grenier griner
right